[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN GRANT: Hi.
I'm Brian Grant.
I'm a principal
engineer at Google.
And I'm here today with
Aparna Sinha, product manager
on Kubernetes and
Container Engine,
and Brandon Philips, CTO CoreOS.
And I'm going to talk to you
about how and why we built
the Kubernetes community,
which is one of the things that
really sets Kubernetes
apart from the other content
orchestration projects and
products that are out there.
So application
containers-- you've
been hearing a lot
about the conference.
They're an increasingly
popular way
to accelerate application
development and deployment.
But containers alone
often aren't sufficient
for managing containers
and production at scale.
You need a container
orchestration system
like Kubernetes.
I like to think of Kubernetes
as a container-centric
infrastructure for managing
and deploying applications.
Kubernetes was
created by Google,
drawing on experience
with Borg, the system that
runs Search and
G-Mail, but Kubernetes
was designed to run anywhere.
I previously worked
on Borg and have
been involved with Kubernetes
since its inception.
We open-sourced
Kubernetes in 2014
and created the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation
to host the Kubernetes
project, and also
to foster an ecosystem of
cloud native infrastructure.
As you can see from this
graph of commits over time,
Kubernetes has been
growing very fast.
We sustained a
steady pace of growth
in the original Kubernetes
repository, which
is what this graph shows--
now with more than
43,000 commits.
But changes to this
original repository
account for fewer than half
of all changes to the project.
So it really is
growing very fast.
It's been estimated that
over 400 years of work
have been put into Kubernetes
in just the last three years.
This growth has been fueled
by growth of contributors.
We started with
fewer than a dozen
and now we have around 150
active monthly contributors
to the project, and over 1,500
all-time unique contributors.
We have contributors
in most time zones,
including countries like
Brazil, India, China,
and all over the world.
In fact, anywhere you
go, you're likely to find
an active Kubernetes
contributor community.
So where does all
this growth come from?
Google has been increasing
its investment in Kubernetes
over the past few years.
We've been doubling
in size every year.
But the community has
grown even faster.
So in the first year, Google
accounted for about 3/4
of all the changes
to Kubernetes.
Now, we're responsible
for less than half.
We worked actually
really, really hard
to onboard all these new
contributors onto the project,
and Google engineers spend
a substantial fraction
of their time helping other
contributors on the product
onboard and be successful.
So we put all this work
into growing the community
because we found that
engagement with the community
yields numerous benefits.
Engagements with users helps
those users be successful
with the project,
and it also provides
rapid feedback that drives
improvements to Kubernetes.
And both the improvements
and the direct help to users
create advocates for the
project to blog and tweet
about it, who
present at meet-ups
and grow awareness
of the product, which
then attracts more users.
And more users and more usage
also attracts developers,
and the developers build
tools and other projects
that help make Kubernetes
easier to use--
things like package
managers, chat bots,
platform as a service,
functions as service,
event driven automation.
I have a document six
pages long with just a list
of interesting projects
built on Kubernetes.
And we see that this empowerment
to improve the project
increases their commitment and
spurs innovation of even more
projects based on Kubernetes.
These users and
developers additionally
attract vendors, who try
to fill the remaining
gaps in the ecosystem.
And we help these vendors
integrate with Kubernetes
and that enables Kubernetes
in more environments
and for more users.
So all of this creates
this virtuous cycle
that has made Kubernetes one
of the most popular projects
on GitHub with over
20,000 [INAUDIBLE] stars.
But we like to say Kubernetes
isn't just open source--
it's an open community.
The open community
encourages not only
direct contributions but
also sharing best practices,
examples, tools.
And we find that not only
vendors and developers
are contributing,
but also our users.
For example, a
co-founder of Box,
who is using Kubernetes
in production on premise,
actually wrote the initial
version of the Kubernetes
command line tool.
And people may contribute
for personal or corporate
recognition, or they may
contribute to Kubernetes
to make it better suit their
needs just because it's
cheaper than building their
own solution from scratch.
Or they may do it
for the greater good,
because making Kubernetes better
makes it better for everyone
and benefits everyone,
not just Google.
In fact, our community
is often cited
by users who talk about
their experience as one
of the main reasons
they chose Kubernetes
over the alternatives.
People say that they want
to be part of a community
where other members
of the community
give back to the
community as well.
So there are costs and
risks associated with having
such an open community.
It's not all the
positive, so I did
want to cover the challenges.
First, it's extremely
time-consuming.
We have a lot of interaction
with users, developers,
vendors, everybody in
lots of different forums--
Twitter, Slack, GitHub, email
lists, Meetups, conferences,
interviews.
So that engagement
provides all the benefits
I just talked about, but
it is very time-consuming.
And it's not just
a nine-to-five job.
A lot of people contribute to
Kubernetes in the evenings,
on the weekend-- they do it for
fun, not part of their day job.
And like I said before,
they do it in time zones
all over the world.
We found that while GitHub
is really good for building
a community of open
source contributors,
it makes it really
challenging to manage
a large project with large
teams and many different moving
pieces.
Decision making, while it
can lead to better decisions
because you get a
diverse set of inputs,
it also does slow down
decision making to some degree.
So you have to be aware of that.
And finally, effort is not
allocated on the project
like it would be if it were just
executed by a single company.
A single company
can control how much
work is put into features versus
code quality, for example,
or documentation.
And with people contributing
under their own objectives
and not under your
control, steering people
to meet all the needs of
the project is challenging.
So now, I'm going to
hand off to Aparna,
who's going to talk to you about
some of the processes of how
the project actually works.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you, Brian.
So Brian mentioned
some of our challenges,
and we are actively
working on challenges,
and they are always upcoming.
We're only three
years old as far
as open source projects goes.
Kubernetes is still
kind of a toddler.
There are certain
things, though,
that we have learned in our
three years of reasonably
well success as far as number
of contributors and number
of contributions.
Here are the principles
that we've learned.
The number one principle
is that of inclusion.
And by inclusion, we mean that
we are a welcoming community,
and we value and respect
diversity of opinion.
This is easier said than done.
We have a lot of very senior
engineers on this project--
a lot of them from Google
and from other companies.
And it can be
difficult to disagree.
It can be difficult to be
open-minded and include
other opinions and reconcile
those, especially when there
is time pressure.
We have a release cadence, where
we release every three months.
And there is time pressure
to make those decisions.
So in those circumstances,
we've actually
found it's even more
important to be inclusive
and to be respectful.
And we've got a code
of conduct around that.
And we actually benefit--
particularly Google--
benefits from this principle
of inclusion because it takes
us outside of our sandbox
and our limited
view and gives us
a much better view
of the full set
of users, both within Google
and then outside of Google,
that will be using
this as a platform.
So that's the number one
principle, is inclusion.
Another aspect of
inclusion is that we
have this process called--
this construct,
organizational construct--
called special interest groups.
When a project gets to
be large like Kubernetes,
it is important to push
the decision making down
to the actual people who
are building the features.
And that's what the
SIGs allow us to do.
Each of the SIGs
is a combination
of people from
different companies
and different organizations
that have gotten together
because they're interested
in a particular topic--
a particular technical topic--
and they want to move the needle
in Kubernetes on that topic.
These are two examples.
There's a SIG called
Cluster Lifecycle SIG.
And their main task
there is to make sure
that Kubernetes is easy
to install and deploy
in a variety of
different environments.
This is a hard problem.
Kubernetes has
become very popular
and is fundamentally a
portable cluster orchestrator.
That means that you can
deploy it on Bare Metal.
You can deploy it on any of
the various public clouds,
all of which have slightly
different networking, slightly
different load balancing, and
slightly different storage.
So it needs to be able
to be installed easily
on a variety of
different environments.
In fact, last year we got
some feedback from our users
that Kubernetes is becoming
hard to install and hard to use,
and that day one
experience isn't very good.
SIG Cluster
Lifecycle, which, you
see some of the companies
that are involved in it--
Weaveworks, CoreOS, Heptio,
obviously Google, and others.
SIG Cluster Lifecycle
kicked into high gear,
and within one release they
came out with a much simpler
two-command install experience--
a command line experience that
is labeled Cube ADM. And then
over the last two
quarters, they've
built out a roadmap
that is resonating
much more with users.
What they're doing is they're
taking some of the building
blocks from Cube
ADM and making them
reusable across all
the different methods
of installation,
bringing consistency
and ease of use across
different environments.
This type of hard problem--
it's hard for one
company to solve it
because you don't
necessarily have a view
across the different platforms.
But when multiple interested
parties get together,
they have a better view of
the problem and a better shot
at solving this type of issue.
Another example is
SIG Service Catalog.
This is also a collaboration
between different companies.
They got together
and they worked
on a common standard for service
to service communication,
as well as for services to
be consumed in Kubernetes.
They borrowed and
worked collaboratively
with Cloud Foundry, which is
another open source project,
and brought the two
projects closer together.
And jointly, we're working to
establish the Open Services
Broker API.
This was announced, I
think, earlier this year.
That's a great example of
skating to where the puck is.
This SIG is enabling
service management
in a way that will be used
at scale in the future.
Those are just two examples.
We have over 25 special
interest groups,
and you can see
some of the areas
that the community is
particularly passionate about.
And each of these
is an active group,
and these SIGs are
always evolving.
So it's kind of like
different stars--
they're colliding and
collapsing and the new ones
are being born as the interest
and the problems of our users
change.
That's a very good sign.
That's a very healthy
sign of the community.
One of the challenges
when you have
this type of distributed
leadership and distributed
decision making--
while that helps
you scale, it is
difficult to keep them all
informed and coordinated.
And so that's one of our
challenges in Kubernetes,
is how do we make sure that
the SIGs are aware of what
the other SIGs are doing?
This comes to a head
when we do a release.
So we've had cases
where one SIG developed
a feature and another SIG wasn't
aware of what was going on
and then after the
release, we found
that there was a bug that then
we needed to do a patch on.
So this is what brings me to
our second principle, which
is that of transparency.
Transparency is extremely
important in a project
of this size.
What that means to
us is that we really
overtrain on being open
with everything that we do,
especially all of our
technical content.
There's only really
one place for it,
which is GitHub Issues
and GitHub Proposals.
It's all developed in the
open-- the designs are,
the problems are.
There's a lot of back and
forth between the engineers
and between different
companies on GitHub.
By some measure, Kubernetes
is one of the most talkative
communities.
I think the measure is actually
a number of comments per issue.
We have a lot of
comments on every issue.
So that makes it great
in terms of transparency.
Also, all of our
discussions and meetings
are recorded and
available to the public.
But the community
is not the only one
who benefits from this.
Actually at the end of the day,
the users benefit the most.
And I think that's one of
the attractions of Kubernetes
and of open source projects
in general that have
this level of transparency--
is that what you
see is what you get.
So the code that's in the
open and the discussions that
are in the open-- that's
exactly what you get.
There isn't a lot of marketing.
There isn't a lot
of positioning,
and users actually
really appreciate that.
So with the emphasis
on transparency
comes a large volume
of information.
As I mentioned, we
are a very comment-
and discussion-oriented
community,
so it's difficult to actually
manage that information
overflow.
And Brian alluded to this.
It's a 24/7 global kind of job
for everyone who's involved.
Some of the constructs that
we have for organizing this
are these meetings.
We have a weekly
community meeting.
Sarah Novotny, who was in
the keynote this morning--
she leads that meeting,
and she kicks it off
by welcoming everybody,
and then there's a demo.
So every meeting
there's a demo, where
the latest and greatest feature
from one of the community
members gets demoed and others
have a chance to give feedback.
But it's also really
exciting because usually
in these community meetings--
which are, by the way,
open to the public.
You are all welcome
to come to these.
You'll see the
latest innovation,
and that's really
exciting actually.
After that, each of the
SIGs give an update.
And that's one of
the ways that we
ensure this SIG-to-SIG
communication
so that we don't have those
kinds of issues, where
one SIG developed a
feature and the other SIG
didn't know about it.
Each of the SIGs gives an update
about what they're working on
for the release, and then
if there are dependencies
that are discussed, those
can be taken offline
and the SIGs can work together.
It's not perfect,
but it's better
and we're evolving every day.
Then we also have the
burndown meetings.
The burndown meetings
are release-specific,
so we are right now just about
to put out the 1.6 release.
We will have burndown meetings--
these are again cross-company,
across the community.
And we will discuss
every single issue
in the burndown meeting
for that release.
We don't generally
hold the release.
We have, as I mentioned,
a three-month cadence.
And having that process
actually takes a lot of stress
out of the whole process--
having that release
cadence of three months.
So we don't hold the release.
If an issue doesn't
make it this week,
then it will make it
in the next 12 weeks.
The only thing
that we hold it for
is if there is a quality issue.
And then the last piece
here is the roadmap process.
And the community meetings
and burndown meetings
are great, but how do
you get a view of what
the project is trying to
achieve on a longer range?
Roadmap process is
also a work in progress
and is something that I've
been responsible for, along
with others in the community.
The heart of this
process is what we have
called the features repository.
It's a repository
where it essentially
serves as our publicly open
backlog for the project.
Again, anyone here can
go to the features repo
and you can see what
are the features that
are coming in the next release.
And you can see their
status as they evolve.
Obviously not everything
makes it and things
change during the
course of the release,
but it's extremely open.
You can go there
and you can see it.
And that provides visibility, of
course, internally to the team
as well-- to the
different SIGs--
because they can see what
each SIG is working on
and how that impacts.
We have a feature freeze.
So what can go into the
repo-- it shouldn't always
be evolving, obviously,
because there
has to be some predictability.
So two weeks into
the 12-week release,
we freeze the features repo.
Anyone can go ahead and make
a recommendation of what
should be in the features repo.
They have to go to
their respective SIG
and make sure that that feature
has a design proposal that
has been reviewed by the
lead engineers in the SIG,
and the SIG overall has
agreed to work on it.
But then two weeks into the
release, that repo is frozen.
The repo then also
drives the release notes
and the documentation
for the release.
Often in open source projects,
and certainly in ours,
documentation has been
a major challenge--
getting the docs to reflect
what has actually been developed
in a way that is
consumable by users given
the breadth of the
project and the intensity
of the technical teams working
on it-- can be difficult.
But having a central repository
allows us to at least plan
for that, and also gate features
if they aren't well documented.
Lastly, we've just started doing
annual and semiannual planning.
This is where we get
the community together--
all the different SIGs.
We get them together
in an unconference
to talk about the
state of the project
and what we want to do
with it in the coming year.
So we had a meeting in
December to talk about 2017
and what Kubernetes
should aim for in 2017.
And there were three top-level
things that came out of that.
One is that we have to
work to scale the project,
and so making
contribution easier,
making changes to
improve our velocity
to scale the
project-- that's one
of our top priorities
as an example.
Number two, we want to make it
easier for people to customize
and add objects to our API
without having to restart,
reboot Kubernetes.
So that's another
thing in API Federation
and associated features
is another track
for the whole of 2017.
And then the third,
related to extensibility,
is ensuring conformance.
Kubernetes has
become quite popular.
There are many distributions.
I think Brian recently counted.
There are 30 or
so distributions.
What is important to
users and one of the value
propositions of
Kubernetes is that it
is interoperable and portable
between these environments.
In order to ensure
that interoperability,
we're working on a set
of conformance tests
so that each of
these distributions
is conformant at
least at a base layer.
So those are our
three themes for 2017.
There are others, but having
this type of unconference
on a semiannual basis allows
us to get together and plan.
So transparency, inclusion,
and some of these processes
are good, and they're
working for us.
But they would not mean
anything if we didn't have
the principle of ownership.
Ownership in Kubernetes has
a very specific meaning,
which is, first of all,
we encourage everyone
in the community to take
responsibility and own a role.
There are many roles.
You can see some of them here.
You can be a contributor,
you can lead a SIG,
you can be part of the
product management group.
There are many roles
in the release process
that you can take.
So there are engineering
and non-engineering roles
in the project.
But what ownership means is
not just that we encourage
people to take these roles, but
that we also respect that role.
And so people have a
chance to take on roles
that they don't formally have.
They haven't necessarily tried.
We have engineers that do
product management and product
managers that do
release management
and so on and so forth.
Respect for the owner means
that others in the community
will step back and allow the
person that is taking that role
and owns that role
to really define
the community's answer for
that particular responsibility.
And that allows
us to grow people
into these different areas.
Speaking of growth, one of
our challenges and something
that we're working actively
on is growing people
through the contributor ladder.
We want to have a lot
more of our users--
and many of our users actually
want to become contributors.
We want to make it easy for
them to join as contributors
and then move up the
ladder as they become
more facile and more well-known
in the Kubernetes community
to become reviewers,
approvers, and ultimately
a very select group of folks
that are in the owners file.
This is the contribution path.
People in the
community are rewarded
for their ownership and
the responsibilities
that they take, often in
the form of homemade awards
but also blog mentions
and PR mentions.
The release team is
often a critical one,
and they are ones that
get a lot of gratitude
from the community.
Also Kubernetes has
become well enough known
that people who
take on these roles
and move up through
these ladders
put that on their resume.
And that is a qualification
that follows them
from company to company as
they go on in their career.
As we mentioned, we
don't know everything,
and we especially don't
know of the challenges that
will come as we scale
this project further.
So we have several
learning mechanisms.
We do retrospectives
after every release
to talk about what went well
and what didn't go well.
These retrospectives are
unique in that it's not
a small group of--
within my company, the
people that I know.
But this is an open public
retrospective with people
from many companies.
And so it's very common
in Kubernetes ideas
to get feedback from
someone over a chat
or over the Slack channel and to
take that very, very seriously,
and for that type of feedback
to actually be career enhancing.
So that was about
our community and how
it functions and the processes.
This is a bit of user feedback.
And what we found
is that the users,
while they like the technology--
Kubernetes has got
a lot of heritage
from the different
companies that
have been contributing to it in
terms of the technology itself.
But really, I think the users
have been telling us that they
value the transparency.
They value the what you see is
what you get and the openness,
and they value the community.
They like the fact that
they can contribute
and they can
influence, and they can
work with all the different
companies that are involved.
We recently did a survey.
Actually, this survey
is still in progress.
This is some early
feedback where
I wanted to understand--
so this open source
software-- how well accepted
and how important it
is to companies that are large
in size-- enterprise companies.
And as you can see here,
more than 50% of enterprises
say that open source
software is either
very important or moderately
important to them.
So why is that?
And these are some
of the benefits
that they say are important.
Number one, the ability
to customize it.
And that's particularly
true with Kubernetes
because if you want to
install it on premise,
you can add and modify--
adjust almost all
of the components--
the scheduler, the
monitoring solution,
the networking solution.
Pretty much all parts
of it are adaptable
and can be changed and adjusted.
The other one, which I
think is very interesting,
is the lower barrier to entry.
Obviously, it's free, and
many of our ultimate customers
start out trying it.
And so by the time they actually
use a commercial version,
and any of them-- any of
the commercial versions--
they already have experience.
They have tried
it out and they've
decided that this is really
what they want to do.
And they've become sometimes
contributors and members
of the community already,
which makes it easier
to work together.
And then I think the last two,
or the second two after this--
faster rate of innovation and
the elimination of lock-in
that comes with
proprietary software.
Those are also
extremely important.
I think the faster
rate of innovation
is something that if
you join our community
or if you're already
members of the community,
you will see that.
It's actually, I would
say arguably faster
than the innovation that takes
place inside any of the member
companies.
As example of user
contributions,
this is just a sampling
of some of the user talks
that are coming up.
So we have our annual
conference for Kubernetes--
biannual conference
for Kuberentes--
coming up in two
weeks in Berlin.
And these are a sampling
of some of the user talks.
One of the things that
users tell us they
enjoy most is not talking to
Google or a CoreOS or Red Hat
or any of the vendors,
but talking to other users
about how did they
do the deployment.
And this is some of the
currently trending areas
of interest.
So how do you deploy Kubernetes
in a private cloud OnPrem
environment with
Legacy load balancers?
How do you use PostgreSQL
in a clustered HA set up
with Kubernetes?
And Zalando will be
talking about how they're
doing that using stateful sets.
Our users are using TensorFlow
on top of Kubernetes
with GPUs on different
types of clouds.
This is actually
information that's
very helpful from a product
and planning perspective
because I can see what the
users are interested in
and we can focus our roadmap
on meeting their needs.
And some of the others--
CI/CD migration-- that's
a very common one.
Many of our users have
reference architectures
that they have
developed for that
and they share with each other.
We also see a lot of
migration from a variety
of different PaaSes
to Kubernetes.
So that was a little
bit about our users.
And I mentioned that as
a Google product manager,
I have a view of what our
users are doing on Google.
But by being a member
of the community,
I can get a much better
view of the whole elephant
and what our users are
doing in other clouds
and what they are
looking for on premise.
That's where our
partner with some
of the members of
our community--
and I'm going to invite
Brandon Philips, who
is the CTO of CoreOS.
CoreOS has been one
of the first companies
to join the
Kubernetes community,
and they bring a perspective
from both on premise and multi
cloud and hybrid users
that I'd like you to hear.
[APPLAUSE]
BRANDON PHILIPS: Cool.
Thank you for the introduction.
So what I wanted to talk about
was our involvement inside
of the Kubernetes project
and some of the customers
that we have been
working with and what
we've been seeing
in the community,
and our strategy in interacting
with the Kubernetes community
overall.
So just for a little background,
CoreOS started in 2013.
Ironically, back
then we had thought
that one of the biggest risks
that we would have starting
the company was that the market
wouldn't understand containers.
I think that risk
has been mitigated
with all the excitement
over the last few years.
But what we're really
trying to do is two things.
One is that we're trying to--
as a big overarching theme--
we like to say that we're
trying to secure the internet.
And that's the long-term
mission of the company.
Now, the tactic that
we take is that we
try to take best
practices that have
been seen in a lot of
these internet giants.
What we used to call GIFEE,
or Google's Infrastructure
for Everybody Else--
and bring these
technologies and help
companies and organizations
be successful with them.
So that's what we do at CoreOS.
And so we started our journey
particularly around Kubernetes,
before even Kubernetes
came out, we
had a project that
we had introduced
called Fleet into the market.
We started this in late
2013, and we were trying
to fill this white space.
Containers are great, but they
were stuck on single hosts.
And so we built this
clustering system,
and it was built on a bunch
of different technologies used
by a bunch of different
organizations.
And it was going pretty well,
and then unbeknownst to us,
there was a great set of
people inside of Google
working on Kubernetes.
And so this project was
introduced a few months--
about six to eight months
after we started Fleet.
And so pretty rapidly
we saw that Kubernetes
filled in a lot of the gaps that
we were planning to build out
in Fleet, and so we
decided to join up
with the Kubernetes community.
And we've been deeply
involved pretty much ever
since the beginning
of the project.
And the reason that
I think Kubernetes
got such a huge
start initially was
that it was really informed by
a lot of Google's experience
running these sorts of
systems in production.
All right.
So what is our journey
that we take with customers
on a regular basis?
Often times, customers are not
going to start-- particularly
people who are just thinking
about that cloud transition,
just learning and understanding
containers-- they're not
going to start by just
biting off Kubernetes
from the very beginning.
So what we do is we help a
lot of different organizations
think about what is
their cloud strategy,
start thinking about containers
and how that influences
and changes the way that
organization works together,
bring these things together
in different environments
with some of our products--
and then moving them through the
transition towards Kubernetes
and the Kubernetes product
that we have called Tectonic.
So it really is not
just a technology choice
for a lot of these
organizations,
but it's also a choice
of making changes
about how they approach
software development,
and also how they approach
rolling out and managing
this infrastructure.
So in particular, what we
do with our products is
we like to say that they are
self-driving, which really
is just this continuous
process of delivering
the latest in open
source technology
into customers' environments,
getting feedback
from those customers
on what's working well,
what isn't working well, having
our engineering teams directly
involved inside
of the communities
to ensure that those projects
are representing what they
actually need, and then
continuing that cycle
release after release.
What we like to say
is that we deliver
pure upstream Kubernetes
for our customers,
but we do it in a
particular way that
enables them to actually digest
and get ahold of that value.
So in order to have this
cycle where we aren't waiting
for months or years before
delivering an open source
project to an
enterprise, we obviously
need to be deeply involved
in the release process
to ensure that the open
source projects are delivering
something that can be
used right of the shelf
without modifications by
these large organizations.
And so one of the things
that has evolved inside
of the Kubernetes is our
involvement in the release
process, but also a
really rigorous release
process that is adopted
by the entire community.
So one of the really unique
things about Kubernetes
as an open source
project is it's
taken a very practiced
and pragmatic approach
to release management.
So inside of Kubernetes we
essentially, at any given time,
have three releases going on.
We have the latest release--
the latest minor
release is what we call
it, which right now is 1.5.
We have then two
releases that we continue
to maintain with security
fixes and bug fixes,
and these are available to
users of our product Tectonic,
available to users of
Google's GKE, et cetera.
But what this means
is that customers
are given nine to 12
months of time period
from when they adopt
something to it continuing
to get security updates to
it essentially to eventually
becoming end of life.
So they have a very
long confidence window
of a particular
release being something
that they can rely on for
a long period of time.
And then obviously, throughout
that entire process,
these are minor
release bumps, and we
ensure that the
upgrade paths are well
tested and well understood.
So to give you a sense of
what these minor releases look
like--
Aparna touched on
this a little bit--
we are currently in the
middle of a release cycle.
Kubernetes 1.6 is
the next release
that will be coming out.
And so we essentially run
through this calendar,
where we spend about
four or six weeks coding
depending on the release.
We go through a
number of alphas,
we go through and do a
beta, we start code freezes,
and then we finally
release the project.
And we this about every quarter,
every three months or so.
And meanwhile, as security
vulnerabilities come out,
as bug fixes are needed, we
are making these back port
and cherry pick releases into
the 1.5, 1.4, and 1.3 branches.
So one of the things
about open source software
and good software
practices in general
is that it's not an
individual member that
makes it really successful.
It takes a big team, and
inside of Kubernetes,
there's a lot of
people involved--
from product managers to
documentation people to people
doing triage of incoming bugs,
and then at the very top is
a person who is overall
responsible for the release--
the release manager.
And their goal is
to one, make sure
the entire team is filled in,
and then two, that the release
actually happens on time.
So one of the things
that's happened
in this release--
the 1.6 release
that I'm really happy about-- is
that CoreOS has gotten involved
and one of our
engineers, Dan Gillespie,
is the release manager for
this release in 1.6, which
is pretty cool because
this is the continuing
effort of the community to
make all the responsibilities
of the project across
different organizations that
are involved.
So this will be
the first release
where the release manager
isn't a Google employee,
and I think this is an important
milestone for the project.
So another piece of
releasing is testing.
Now, we have this
diagram of Kubernetes
that we used earlier.
There's a lot of moving
parts inside Kubernetes,
as this diagram would
lead you to believe.
And what we do is a really,
really sophisticated set
of testing.
If you haven't taken a look
at the Kubernetes dashboards
at any point, a lot
of it allows you
to drill down across a
lot of different metrics,
across different
cloud providers,
across different deployment
types, et cetera,
and drill down and see is
the code actually healthy?
Is it operating as it should?
One of my favorite dashboards
that Kubernetes has
is of individual
nodes where we're
able to drill down and see how
much memory is being consumed,
how much CPU is being
consumed across the test.
Another big change that we've
had in the last few months
is that we've made the security
release process something that
is run by the community.
So security releases are pretty
important to any open source
software, and it's really
easy to make these things
sort of an ad hoc process.
Security vulnerabilities come
out every couple of months
no matter how good your
engineering practices are,
and so for a lot of
projects, they just
deal with them as they come.
But one of the things that
Kubernetes community has
done well is that we
identify a problem,
we try to create a process
to fix that problem reliably
time and time again, and
delegate responsibilities
of getting that thing fixed.
And so the security
release process
allows the community to go
through, handle disclosures
quickly, figure out
a communication plan
with the users,
communicate that plan
and actually give
them actionable data.
We'll be running
through this process
every time that somebody
discloses an issue,
whether it ends up being an
actual security-impacting issue
or not.
And at the end, we try to
make a retrospective of, hey,
did this security
process actually work?
What can we do better next time?
Et cetera.
This is a quote in the SRE--
the Site Reliability Engineering
book--
there's this idea of
blameless retrospectives.
And this is one
that I really like--
the cost of failure
is education.
And this is really about, if
our security process doesn't
go well or our release
process doesn't go well,
all we can do is reflect on what
didn't go well, get together
as a team, and actually improve
the process for the next time
around.
Cool.
So a big reason that I think
Kubernetes has gotten extremely
popular, and one of the things
that we're directly involved
in, is making
Kubernetes successful
wherever people have
compute network in storage.
And we've done this
in a variety of ways.
The dream for people
of cloud portability
is that you're able to build
an application for the cloud
and then you're able to run it
in your existing data center.
For a lot of people, they
have a data center footprint
of some sort.
You're able to run it on
your individual developers'
machines, so they are able
to have a local dev test
environment.
You're able to deploy it into
a public cloud environment,
maybe run it on a second
cloud environment, which
we're finding is a very common
pattern for a lot of people--
and maybe a third
cloud environment.
And so as an example of this, we
have a customer, Ticketmaster,
that we've worked with.
I was surprised when we started
working with Ticketmaster.
I didn't realized they are a
40-year-old technology company.
But as a 40-year-old
technology company,
they have a lot of challenges.
They have a lot of
virtual machine footprint.
They have about 22,000
virtual machines
that they manage on
their own data centers
that they've purchased
all the hardware for.
They have a lot of
different products.
They have a lot of different
engineers, et cetera.
But what they deal with
every day is what they call
their self-inflicted DDOS
as a service, which is,
when a new concert
ticket comes out--
maybe Beyonce has
announced a new tour--
they essentially have this
one moment in time where
they get a ton of traffic.
And obviously they would like
to move a lot of this traffic
and a lot of this responsibility
onto a public cloud.
And so with Kubernetes,
we're helping
them to deploy Kubernetes
both in their data center
and to move some of their
workload to the public cloud.
And that's all enabled
because of the abstractions
and because of the
technology of Kubernetes.
And so in order
to get them there,
in order to get a lot of these
companies there, what we do
is that we fill in a lot of
the white spaces for where
Kubernetes is not able to
adapt to any environment.
So some of the things that
we've introduced over time
are things like Dex, which
is an identity provider that
allows people to plug in to
their existing Active Directory
LDAP services, or other things
like Flannel, where we're
able to bring the Kubernetes
opinion and model of networking
across any public cloud
or into people's data
centers with ease, without a
lot of work with their network
operations team.
And that goes across a lot of
what we do in the open source.
We work closely with Kubernetes.
We fill in white
spaces where Kubernetes
is unable to go where
we need it to go.
And we continue to
iterate and make sure
that it is successful as
a multi cloud platform.
So what Kubernetes is at the
end of the day is really,
I think, a way of expressing a
consumption of compute network
and storage that can
be used and abstracted
across any sort
of infrastructure.
And that means
that whether you're
using Google Cloud or any of
the other public clouds, or even
Bare Metal, Kubernetes
should reliably
work in the exact same
way across those systems.
And it's our responsibility,
as members of the Kubernetes
communities, and
companies helping
to make these users successful,
that we build the technology
in such a way that
this is actually true
and that we can bring
this idea to fruition.
So I just wanted to end with a
quick recap about the journey
that we've gone through
with Kubernetes and really
what it's trying to tackle.
Kubernetes is this
container-centric
infrastructure and
software that's
designed to help people use
some of the best practices that
have evolved from Google and
other people over the years.
It's a system that's designed
to run anywhere, whether you're
in your cloud provider,
on your laptop,
or in your Bare
Metal environments.
It is a huge active community.
We have people from
all over the globe,
like Aparna said, participating.
And those people aren't
just necessarily engineers.
We have very talented product
managers and documentation
experts, who are making
the project not just a fun
open source science experiment,
but an interesting and useful
product that people can
actually take off the shelf
and use in their
infrastructure today.
And with all these data
points that we've discussed,
it's actively in use by
large organizations today.
I think it's really easy
as software engineers
to get excited about how
cool a technology, is
but really the
value of technology
doesn't come out until
you have somebody
who is actively using it and
giving you that feedback.
And I'm really happy
to say that Kubernetes
is doing that on a
very regular basis
with a growing number of
organizations using it.
And of course, there's
a lot of fun as well.
This community is a
super dynamic community.
People are excited about the way
that we're developing software.
They're excited about
working with each other
across different organizations.
And I think that is an
important part of building
any sort of community.
With a little bit of
branding and a good group
of people and some
good processes,
you can build something
awesome and we're
doing that at Kubernetes
So with this, I'd like to invite
you to join all of us working
on Kubernetes at
github.com/kubernetes.
There you can find the code,
but also importantly information
on how to find us all--
so the mailing lists,
the community Hangouts,
all the details that you
might need to get involved.
And if you ever
have any questions,
there's a lot of friendly people
that will answer you either
on our Slacker mailing list.
No question will be
rejected, so please join us.
And with that, I thank
you for your attention.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]